Jake: 看表了
Jake: Look at the watch.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 到了是吧
Jake: We've arrived, right?
Jake: 确实到了
Jake: Yes, we have.
Jake:进去
Jake: Go in.
Jake:进去进去找
Jake: Go in, go look inside.
Jake:拐拐拐
Jake: Turn, turn, turn.
其他人：够荒凉的
Others: It's quite desolate.
Jake: 咱也不知道这是啥地
Jake: We don't even know what this place is.
其他人：嗯信号不好
Others: Yeah, the signal is bad.
其他人：信号不好啊
Others: The signal is really bad.
其他人：走了呢
Others: It's gone.
其他人：应该就这位置了100米
Others: It should be around here, 100 meters.
Jake: 那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
其他人：是不就这
Others: Is it right here?
Shure:  但不是这个
Shure: But it's not this one.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
其他人：不是再往前大铁门
Others: No, it's further ahead, the big iron gate.
Jake: 我我等会
Jake: I, I'll wait a bit.
Jake: 我我我这边看看
Jake: I'll, I'll check this side.
其他人：它不动了
Others: It's not moving.
Jake: 我这边也有地图可以看
Jake: I have a map here too.
Jake: 往前走往前走一会
Jake: Walk ahead, just a bit more.
其他人：往前走
Others: Walk ahead.
其他人：信号不好
Others: The signal is bad.
Jake: 就这个就左边这个
Jake: It's this one, the one on the left.
其他人： 这边手动的啊
Others: This one is manual, huh?
Lucia: 哦这还挂着呢
Lucia: Oh, it's still hanging here.
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Alice:还往前
Alice: Keep going forward.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha:  再往前
Tasha: Go further.
Alice:还得往前
Alice: Still need to go forward.
Tasha:  往前
Tasha: Forward.
Shure:  ah
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  摁下那个星号
Shure: Press the star button.
Jake: 你家是刚刚有猫吗
Jake: Did you just get a cat?
Lucia: 他刚才从那上面跑下来又跳下来
Lucia: It just ran down from there and jumped.
Katrina:  910325是吗
Katrina: 910325, right?
Shure:  不是如果你摁对了
Shure: No, if you pressed it right.
Shure:  他直接自己开
Shure: He just started it himself.
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Mimi
Jake: 你你要先按一个键
Jake: You need to press a button first.
Lucia: 不理我们他走了
Lucia: He ignored us and walked away.
Jake: 在在对你等到他
Jake: Yeah, wait for him.
Jake: 哔对
Jake: Beep, right.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay!
Jake: 牛啊牛啊
Jake: Awesome, awesome.
Shure:  哦太牛了
Shure: Oh, that's amazing.
Shure:  人类居然可以记住6位密码
Shure: Humans can actually remember a 6-digit password.
Shure:  小心点那有那有
Shure: Be careful, be careful.
Shure:  AI 3秒用吗
Shure: Does AI use 3 seconds?
Jake: 三秒开玩笑
Jake: Joking about three seconds.
Shure:  3毫秒
Shure: 3 milliseconds.
Alice:三秒
Alice: Three seconds.
Lucia: 这么简单的事情就不用3秒了是吧
Lucia: Such a simple thing doesn't need 3 seconds, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 3秒带开机吗
Jake: 3 seconds to boot up?
Shure:  开着呢
Shure: It's on.
Jake: 三秒开机
Jake: Three seconds to boot up.
Jake: 放冰箱放完冰箱就结束
Jake: Put it in the fridge, and it's done.
Lucia: 我的留言板
Lucia: My message board.
Lucia: 不是留言板
Lucia: Not a message board.
Lucia: 就是那个软木的那个照片墙
Lucia: It's that cork photo wall.
Katrina:  这个肉要腌吗
Katrina: Do we need to marinate this meat?
Katrina:  还是说先放冰箱
Katrina: Or just put it in the fridge first?
Lucia: 这个东西
Lucia: This thing...
Lucia: 它怎么这么大呀
Lucia: Why is it so big?
Lucia: 我以为它就一点点呢
Lucia: I thought it was just a little bit.
Lucia: 装起来就好
Lucia: Just pack it up.
Katrina:  把肯德基扔了
Katrina: Throw out the KFC.
Shure:  我每天放冰箱意义
Shure: What's the point of putting it in the fridge every day?
Shure:  就是留一天扔掉是吗
Shure: Just to leave it for a day and throw it away?
Shure:  好饿好饿
Shure: So hungry, so hungry.
Shure:  好困好困好累好累
Shure: So sleepy, so sleepy, so tired, so tired.
Lucia: 哎这太夸张了
Lucia: Oh, this is too much.
Lucia: 算了一会再看他
Lucia: Forget it, I'll check it later.
Shure:  要都放里吗
Shure: Should I put them all in?
Katrina: 鸡蛋呢
Katrina: What about the eggs?
Katrina:  扔了
Katrina: Throw them out.
Shure:  放放放
Shure: Put them in, put them in.
Lucia: 前两天买的那个
Lucia: The ones we bought a couple of days ago.
Lucia: 可以先拿出来了今天晚上把它吃了
Lucia: We can take them out and eat them tonight.
Shure:  倒完
Shure: All done.
Lucia: 然后把新的再补充进去
Lucia: Then we can add the new ones.
Lucia: 哦不是这个这个
Lucia: Oh, not this one, this one.
Lucia: 再不吃可能坏了
Lucia: If we don't eat it soon, it might spoil.
Jake: yes yes
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 放到这吧
Lucia: Put it here.
Lucia: 一会把它吃了去
Lucia: Let's eat it later.
Lucia: 调料
Lucia: The seasoning.
Jake: RNB
Jake: RNB.
Lucia: 哦对芒果
Lucia: Oh right, the mango.
Shure:  不用不用
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure:  电子版扫描就行
Shure: Just scan the electronic version.
Katrina:  没拿出吃了吧
Katrina: Didn't take it out and eat it, right?
Katrina:  这几个
Katrina: These few.
Lucia: 我们晚上可以把
Lucia: 让我们那啥
Lucia: Let's...
Lucia: 做那些甜品的时候需不需要用
Lucia: When we make those desserts, do we need...
Katrina:  对这个吗
Katrina: For this?
Lucia: 就草莓和芒果
Lucia: Just strawberries and mangoes.
Lucia: 好像微微之前说做甜点用
Lucia: I think Tasha said to use them for desserts.
Lucia: 可以先放一下
Lucia: We can put them aside first.
Lucia: 然后如果用不着了再把它吃掉
Lucia: And if we don't use them, we can eat them.
Jake: 热量爆炸是吧
Jake: Calorie explosion, huh?
Lucia: 芒果
Lucia: Mangoes.
Lucia: 怎么给我一种好像要尽快吃它的感觉
Lucia: I feel like we need to eat them soon.
Jake: 今天就吃
Jake: Eat them today.
Lucia: 再放可能就
Lucia: If we wait...
Tasha:  那就今天就吃
Tasha: Then let's eat them today.
Jake: 今天今天围绕着他能做什么
Jake: Let's see what we can make with them today.
Katrina:  was ice cream
Katrina: Maybe ice cream.
Tasha:  什么都行
Tasha: Anything works.
Lucia: 对会今天把它做了
Lucia: Yeah, let's use them today.
Jake: 对今天围绕着他
Jake: Yeah, let's focus on them today.
Shure:  我我们我可以
Shure: We, we can...
Shure:  我们可以养小芒狗
Shure: We could raise a little mango dog.
Lucia: 养小芒狗
Lucia: Raise a little mango dog?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 哈哈哈芒果核这个我知道
Jake: Hahaha, I know about mango pits.
Shure:  哈哈哈知道那个吗
Shure: Haha, you know about that?
Alice:就那个芒果盒
Alice: Yeah, that mango pit.
Tasha:  芒果皮芒果狗是吧嗯
Tasha: Mango skin, mango dog, right?
Shure:  芒果核对
Shure: Mango pit, yes.
Lucia: 哦没反应过来
Lucia: Oh, I didn't catch on.
Alice:让他把它嗦嗦嗦
Alice: Let him suck, suck, suck on it.
Lucia: 哎我鞋带没有开
Lucia: Oh no, my shoelace is untied.
Shure:  对嗦嗦干净点
Shure: Yeah, suck it clean.
Lucia: 行今天晚上的活动就是养小小芒果
Lucia: Okay, tonight's activity is raising little mango dogs.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 芒果核
Lucia: Mango pit.
Shure:  不行今天太多了
Shure: No way, there's too much today.
Shure:  明天明天养吧
Shure: Let's do it tomorrow.
Shure:  工作量爆棚了有点
Shure: We're overloaded with work.
Jake: 养芒果要工序很多吗
Jake: Does raising mangoes require a lot of steps?
Lucia: 用就一直搁那吸那个芒果核就行了
Shure:  嗦干净一点就好
Shure: Just suck it clean, that's all.
Lucia: 然后洗一洗
Lucia: And then wash it.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake: 迷惑行为是吧不知道
Jake: It's confusing, isn't it? I don't know.
Shure:  人类为什么会把一个植物的种子
Shure: Why do humans turn a plant's seed into a pet?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  当成一个宠物
Shure: Make it a pet.
Shure:  why human will
Shure: Why human will...
Jake: 您好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 6:11
Jake: 6:11.
Shure:  我靠那是7点 能吃啊
Shure: Damn, it's 7 o'clock. Can we eat?
Jake: 7点开始可达到
Jake: Start at 7.
Tasha:  7点
Tasha: 7 o'clock.
Lucia: 哦这不是那啥
Lucia: Oh, isn't this...
Jake: 7点开始做
Jake: Start cooking at 7.
Alice:开始做快8点吃
Alice: Start cooking, eat around 8.
Lucia: 这个是一会用来喝的
Lucia: This is for drinking later.
Shure:  能快速的把我这个先导完吗
Shure: Can we quickly finish this first?
Lucia: 是吧就不管了
Lucia: Right, just leave it.
Jake: 哈哈哈呃没没法快
Jake: Hahaha, no way to speed it up.
Tasha:  哎牛奶怎么拿出来了
Tasha: Hey, why did you take the milk out?
Alice:是早上的时候吧
Alice: Was it from this morning?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 现在应该还不至于坏
Lucia: It shouldn't be spoiled yet.
Shure:  那个蛋液好像够呛
Shure: That egg mixture looks iffy.
Jake: 蛋液怎么会呢
Jake: How can the egg mixture be bad?
Shure:  那可以停了吗这个先
Shure: Can we stop this for now?
Jake: 结束了吧结束了吧
Jake: Let's wrap this up, okay?
Shure:  结束了吧
Shure: Let's wrap it up.
Shure:  我这个快结束
Shure: I'm almost done here.
Jake: 来快快结束
Jake: Come on, let's finish quickly.
Katrina:  面包要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should the bread go in the fridge?
Alice:不太能
Alice: Probably not.
Lucia: 面包
Lucia: Bread.
Lucia: 要不咱们拿到楼上去放楼上冰箱
Lucia: How about we put it in the upstairs fridge?
Lucia: 我看还有啥要放的
Lucia: I'll see what else needs to go in.
Lucia: 菜就不放了吧
Lucia: Let's not put the veggies in.
Lucia: 一会直接直接用吧
Lucia: We'll use them directly in a bit.
Lucia: 这个也得放冰箱
Lucia: This needs to go in the fridge too.
Lucia: 榴莲这个也要放冰箱吧
Lucia: Should this durian go in the fridge too?
Katrina:  放一楼冰箱吧
Katrina: Put it in the first floor fridge.
Lucia: 冷冻
Lucia: Freeze it.
Lucia: 冷冻的话就放一
Lucia: If freezing, then the first-
Lucia: 楼冰箱就可以了
Lucia: floor fridge is fine.
Alice:这榴莲是准备烤着吃还是怎样的
Alice: Are we planning to bake this durian or what?
Lucia:good
Lucia: Good.
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 这个就放2楼冰箱算了放不下了
Lucia: Let's just put this in the 2nd floor fridge, it's full.
Katrina:  这好像放不下就裂了都
Katrina: It looks like it won't fit, it's already cracked.
Lucia: 那就别放太多别万一对
Lucia: Then don't overfill it, just in case.
Katrina:  不能再放那个酒
Katrina: Can't put the wine in.
Lucia: 着放这好了先
Lucia: Let's just leave it here for now.
Lucia: 咱今天晚上反正要喝一瓶酒对吧
Lucia: We're drinking a bottle of wine tonight anyway, right?
Lucia: 晚上是喝哪瓶
Lucia: Which bottle are we drinking tonight?
Katrina:  气泡酒吧
Katrina: The sparkling one?
Lucia: 喝是喝这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Lucia: 是喝粉红这个好像因为这是今天新买的
Lucia: The pink one, since we just bought it today.
Lucia: 能放下不
Lucia: Will it fit?
Katrina:  嗯我感觉他
Katrina: Hmm, I think it
Lucia: 要不这样把它横放到这里面
Lucia: How about we lay it down horizontally here?
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Careful.
Lucia: 放着也行然后咱喝时候再拿出去
Lucia: It’s fine to leave it like that and take it out when we want to drink.
Lucia: 好像没啥了是吧
Lucia: Seems like that’s it, right?
Lucia: 很完美
Lucia: Perfect.
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 为什么关不上
Lucia: Why won’t it close?
Lucia: 关是能关上
Lucia: It can close.
Lucia:没事不管它
Lucia: It’s fine, just leave it.
Lucia: 对可能有啥放的比较满
Lucia: Yeah, maybe it's too full.
Lucia: 算了用点劲关就行
Lucia: Never mind, just use a bit of force to close it.
Lucia: 我们现在可以停了
Lucia: We can stop now.
Jake: 停停停停了吧
Jake: Stop, stop, stop, let’s stop.
Jake: 对停了对休息时间不得工作
Jake: Yeah, stop, it's break time, no working.
Lucia: 休息时间不得工作
Lucia: Break time, no working.